ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
session that is a live broadcast and
which have the title as you once 6162
clinical studies of a candidate drug
capable of alleviating dysregulation of
the diplomatic system you this is a very
interactive session meaning that you
will be able to pose questions to the
presenter our console and during the
session and for that purpose you should
use the question-and-answer bottom that
you will find it's a green one and you
can find it at the lower left of the air
presentation window and we will try to
answer as many questions as we can at
the end of this presentation if you
should have any problems hearing we're
seeing this presentation you should
could also use the question and answer
button to send in your complaints and
could also use the support button that
you will find on the top right of your
presentation so there are two
possibilities if there are any problems
and during this event with hearing or
seeing and it's my great privilege to be
the moderator and also discussant of
this session my name is Elias Erickson
I'm pharmacologist from Gothenburg
University and it's an honor to have the
opportunity to introduce today's speaker
who is a very prominent person in
psychopharmacology since already since
the late 50s in fact professor arvid
carlsson also from Gothenburg in Sweden
and I recall so was one of the first who
suggested that there is a new chemical
transmission in the brain and that the a
means may serve as transmitters in the
brain when most important players in the
field regarded this is very unlikely so
so but I
subsequently turned out to be right he
also was the first to suggest that dirt
moon is not merely a precursor to modern
and better transmitter in its own sense
which also was controversial at first
but now of course widely recognized it
was also the first to show that dopeman
is important for the regulation or
locomotion which of course paid the babe
a bit pain is related to the treatment
of Parkinson's disease we dope and other
dopaminergic drugs in 1963 I recall some
co-workers first suggested that
antipsychotic drugs act by blocking
catecholamine receptors including
dopamine receptors which of course was
the starting point for the dopeman
theory of schizophrenia and later on
Arvid also also refers to suggest that
part should be to agonist could perhaps
be a have certain advantages in the
treatment of schizophrenia which also
have shown to be true but by what means
some of the re per person I papers on
introduction and has also been acting in
other fields for example in the
serotonin field in fact the first
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor
was invented by cosmic co workers here
in Gothenburg the forerunner of Prozac
so it's really a pioneer in the field
that we will have the privilege to
listen to today and our weed is still
very active in research and he is now
developing in the midst of developing a
new very exciting drug belonging to a
new class of drug often called dopamine
stabilizers and I will now turn to Arvid
and ask you to start this session by by
just briefly into the introduction what
is the dope will stabilize established
subletting drag and and why would this
be important thank you Elias first of
all thank you for your very kind
introduction the LEAs will help you
through this talk to to
make you understand that the molecule
that you see here it's called minus osu
61-62 that this is a very interesting
molecule with some remarkable properties
and as early as already indicated act as
a stabilizer of the dopaminergic system
which is its main action it has some
additional actions but did what we will
focus on to start with is its effect on
on the dopamine system and first of all
how come that we have been so interested
in developing this kind of drug well we
what we wanted to do what to get get
beyond the simplistic characterization
or brain disorders in terms of either
hyper or hypo locomotion of
neurotransmitters so we can just go on
here and and and why is such a concept
sip simplistic well it erroneously
assumes that the dysfunction of a
neurotransmitter is consistent that is
the same in different neural circuits or
at different times and there are good
examples that this is indeed not so and
we can see that here there are good very
good but the two very classical examples
that I want to bring it up here in first
Parkinson's disease here you have a
degeneration of dopaminergic pathways
and and that leads to of course and
problems with motor functions but at the
same time at least in the early stages
of Parkinson's disease this is what you
have I mean the mental functions or
could be intact for a very long time so
that's one one example where the
dopaminergic system is okay in one
respect but certainly not okay in
another
and similarly in schizophrenia psychotic
symptoms are due to hyper function of
dopamine in some pathways but then you
have other dopaminergic pathways that
are controlling motor functions for
example and name it may be intact so
what it means is as we can go on here we
can see that if you have such an
inconsistency if whatever drug you pick
up that is a full-blown one within other
world it attacks or the given
transmitter without any limitation it
will have adverse effects because even
if you correct one pathway the dopamine
function in one pathway that is not in a
good order it several others perhaps the
majority of the top above the pathways
where dopamine is involved or ok so if
now you start with just either
innovating or bringing down the function
throughout our brain you are bound to
have all kinds of of side effects and
examples of these are for example you
have the dual elliptic on the negative
side of dopamine function and and you
have amphetamine acting upwards and
there are many others that will have
such unlimitedly will have considerable
side effects serious side effects
actually and if I may interrupt you
there with the question you you were and
receive the Nobel Prize in all year two
thousand four main if you discover us in
Parkinson's disease you have obviously
spent a lot of time with that disorder
and also you're the first to suggest the
hyperactivity of dopamine in
schizophrenia have you for long been
thinking along these lines that it must
be a difficulty in shutting down or over
stimulating the system I have to confess
I was likely all the others to start
with
it was fair in it was a wonderful idea
that maybe the whole system could act in
this all over the brain dopamine if
dopamine is high in one place it's going
to be high everywhere and so forth so
but of course this the side effects they
became so obvious and the more specific
drugs you develop the more problems you
got so that really showed that there is
something fundamentally wrong in this
simplistic idea I heard you give a
lecture to cmp Congress and stock them a
few years ago and I know that you
expressed some concern about the reports
that antipsychotic drugs may in fact
reduce the size of the brain would you
like to remember that well that's an
important aspect it is with the the
effect that many neurotransmitters have
on the plasticity of the brain the
ability or on the brain to rebuild
itself at a microscopic level and even
at the macroscopic level in order to
adjust to whatever new problems will
come up do in the course of a human
beings life so the one has to bring in
that and there are some these problems
are very difficult to study in a very
controlled way in humans but are also
very interesting studies in macaques in
monkeys and I think of all those that
were happy done in in Pittsburgh and
some other places in the end Denmark for
that Natalie and where it can be seen
that if you treat within neuroleptic
drugs over a fairly short time a couple
of years only and then you you examine
the brains of all these macaques they
are no longer normal they have changes
and the interesting theory at for
example its are certain cortical areas
are reduced in volume
and the interesting thing is that those
that kind of of changes that you see all
the safety changes that you can see in
chronic schizophrenics the famous yes so
the problem is it a disorder or is it a
drugs a very serious problem very hard
to solve this problem with this but you
wouldn't you regard it as a possibility
that they too drastic reduction or
transmission might have such effect that
you would rule out cannot simply cannot
exclude it it's something we must keep
in mind okay okay now as I assume you
believe that your new drug may to some
extent solve this problem or at least
their sister project it's a new it's a
new concept that suppose you can find a
drug that can act at the same time both
upwards and downwards in terms of for
example dopamine function and thus has
to be able to correct at the same time
what is too much and it what is not
enough then it would be there to be a
stabilizers will be drug restabilized
properties and not it may seem like a
miracle but the drug we are they going
to talk about is such a drug in my in my
opinion so what do we see here first of
all this is a model that now in retrofit
working with this for a long time but
now in retrospect I think one can I I
think about a kind of fatty model a way
of of restoring mental fatigue but we
are talking we are talking about animals
now in this case right and what what
what is seen here is that it take a
right to take it out the poor right now
out of a relatively pleasant home cage
put it in a small very unpleasant place
a and and and where it was very of
course what's to get out and to get back
home and and it explores all
possibilities of getting away the end
this but the exploration exploratory
activity goes down and down so what you
can see on the column on the on the left
side here that is what the animal
finally arrives at giving up doing
absolutely nothing and then if now if
you treat the animal with increasing
doses as you can see here on our drug
you can see now it goes it gets up again
in starts once again to explore just too
tough to find out even after all that is
the possibility to get away from this
and actually the increase that you see
here in retrospect now with only the
experience that we had this is actually
a curve so it goes up to a maximum that
did 50 as you can see here and then it
goes down again so it is a curvy we'd
never in the beginning we didn't dare to
to draw it like a curve but with a
maximum at 50 micro Mose the gravity is
perfectly Legrand at this time but but
that is actually what we think today so
that is what is happening in a animal
that is so called habituated before we
go further and just for those not
familiar in this field it could be say
that what you see in the first part of
this car would be what you expect from a
dolphin stimulating drug like
amphetamine or dopamine agonist would
you
with that oh sure if you have an agonist
it can do that the problem with the
agonist is that if you when you increase
it as it goes up and happen then it ends
up in a in a terrible way with stereo
stereotyped behavior and all kinds of
problems but with this with this kind of
drug it goes up to a certain point which
is a run of moderate degree of activist
certain no hyperactivity and but and if
you go beyond that it starts to go down
again but not very dramatic very
interesting we now have another picture
yes this this is one curve well actually
statistically it can be shown that we
are indeed dealing with a curve with
with with with low doses of the drug up
going activity we british motor activity
all the time that we are measuring here
in the previous slide it happened to be
a rat but this time it is is mama mice
that we are looking at so if we go up to
a a level here this is in milligram per
kilo in this case and the where you
tutor the level by you have is the star
above you have a significant increase
with dosage if you go beyond it in for
tots or right from the point indicated
by the star it goes down again so it's a
biphasic curve and that is exactly what
it should be in theory and and because
we are this is what something i'm iming
it later on we will understand that you
have well you have on one force that is
working in upward direction and another
word and in another in downward
direction and in this particular mice
have a level an intermediate kind of
level on motor activity so you can pick
up so nicely this by facing curve now we
have rodents with another degree of
activity yes these are now we are back
to rats again by the way and they are
now brought from their home cage all
right but now they are brought into a an
area with lots of of interesting new
objects that have must be investigated
carefully so they are up in a very high
activity and if now do you give
increasing doses you started you thought
let's see it you have the controls at
the far left and then you give
increasing doses or one and the same
drug all the time or fabulous drag and
then it's going downwards so and in this
case it's it what is needed here is
somewhat higher doses and those that on
that were needed in the beginning there
is inactive animals to activate them so
but but finally you you will get this
inhibitory effect and that is what is
the only thing that shows up here in
this picture so then we have perhaps a
feature of a antipsychotic drug for
example anti-doping drag and what about
other well-known effect of these drugs
that are anti doping for example
catalepsy is a well-known phenomenon for
almost all and Tsikata drugs t2 blocking
with exceptional clozapine do you get
that with high doses of destroy now that
is of course the remarkable aspect of
the whole thing that you can go down you
do get down to a very narrow activity
but when you test for catalepsy that is
it's not has been possible yet to see
any sign any any sign of catalepsy and
just to go one step further from he
here to humans you don't see with with
this drug in the extrapyramidal side
effects as you know catalepsy predict
for these extra parameter side of it so
this drug can it doesn't do that not in
in doses that can be tolerated by human
beings fascinating another this is a
reduction in in spontaneous locomotion
active enemies one like wonder what
would happen if you give a stimulating
drugs such as amphetamine most
neuroleptics can block the hyperactivity
of amphetamine you get an increase or a
reduction in amphetamine use locomotion
by by your compound I haven't put in a
slide on this we have lots of evidence
with several central stimulants and they
all show the same thing they all show
this kind of picture with increasing
doses you get a decrease the only
difference that we have seen is that we
can if we are very careful with dosage
and timing and so on we can pick up at
the low dose of this drug and at the
short type a slight elevation in so you
have a stimulation of the central
stimulant and when you give this drug
you can see during a very short time
after or if the dose is small enough you
can see a certain certain increase but
then it goes down so we had even here we
have a biphasic car it's only that that
the rising part of it is so very small
that you can hardly pick it up I
discussing other situations where you
have may have innovation of dopamine in
the brain Europe we are talking about
very active rats and amphetamine treated
rats and so on I read a paper by stay in
London you co-authored about
ethanol consuming rodents and the effect
of this drug would you like to comment
on that yes we can replicate what I what
we have been talking about how about for
example this with the central stimulants
that as pious claims lancer so nicely
has demonstrated that you if you have if
you have animals that are being used to
24 alcohol intake and which they cannot
like you they are they are they are
abusing the drug and poor animals if you
treat them with this drug you they can
get away from from this problem
obviously this opens up for various
different clinical applications this
type but we will come back to that later
first the last question on this lateral
I would just like to which I think may
need open researchers would like to ask
you that does it display affinity for
the d2 receptor in return revisit this
is it an agonist and antagonist partial
agonist what is it yes that's it it
binds it by and i will show you actually
human data to demonstrate that it can
display the impaired studies you can
displace actually with this drug
radioactive rattler pride from its
binding sites so we have very strong but
we have we have such animal data as well
but it's especially important that we
have very good human data that we come
back to later on so if this is a drug
that binds to dopamine d2 receptors
there is no question about that and you
see in vitro any signs of partial
agonist will destroy yes it it shows is
some intrinsic activity but the
interesting thing is that when we move
from in vitro to in vivo and look very
careful to carefully to see if
we can pick up any intrinsic activity
nobody with nobody has been able to see
that and we have tries really very hard
especially with pro prolactin studies
but the only thing we can see is
evidence of antagonists on the d2
receptors so mostly when people hear
about dopamine stabilization they might
think of partial agonists obsess abilify
but this is you can definitely rule out
that as the possibility that if the
mechanism underlying this absolutely and
in fact if we try partial agonist on the
models especially this the the fatigue
model that the animal fatigue model that
i showed the mean while ago it doesn't
work partial agonist are unable to to
stimulate these fatty these habituated
animals to get up and do another try to
explore the boring cage it's impossible
it's only this kind of drug that can do
that though and of course you can do it
with full-blown agonies but that is weak
as we have already said not a good
solution epson and now i think everyone
is intrigued to hear you explain how
this all might come about and here sir
and i slide please yes so this is a
slide where we need a little bit of
pointer here because what you see you
see these oblique thing which is a now
is a dopaminergic nerve terminal going
all the way through the picture this is
an l a-- by the way of course and an
electro microscopic picture i have
gotten it from susan psycho Pete
Pittsburgh I like this picture very much
p it's extremely informative so if you
have this you now see this nerve
terminal with its bead bead like
extension here
and if we go let's go first to the
synapse if this is rayne deep red the
synapse and and on and it's a
dopaminergic synapse on the postsynaptic
side or the synaptic cleft you have a
thick membrane cell membrane and or in
those six cell members there are
receptors dopaminergic receptors are
green here and so they are the ones that
are the entire force adapted to respond
to very high levels of dopamine if we
and I have been marked with a yellow
number one as you can see there and if
we move a little bit upwards from the
you use against a again see this is the
same green symbol of the synapse label
as to hear but now you can see that of
course here the dopamine level in the in
India extracellular space is not is not
deep red anymore it's muttered lower
it's getting blue blue Warren glue or
that's lower and lower and you can go
even further to number three does that
one that this very much level so these
these are now with receptors that are
located outside that our targets for the
dopaminergic and nerve terminals but if
we go back to the dopamine nerve
terminal again we will see that they
also have the same symbols that is d2
receptors green and and they are not in
the synaptic cleft but outside so they
are adapted to much lower concentrations
of dopamine then what we what we have
found is that these receptors that are
located on the
dopaminergic new missile we call them
out of receptors and autoreceptors the
purpose of these autoreceptors is that
if if the concentration of dopamine in
the in the extracellular space tends to
get too high they will respond to the
increase in dopamine level and they will
turn off all kinds of activities of the
dopaminergic neurons and of course if
you have a blocking agent it will do
acting on the d2 receptor they would do
the opposite so these are the auto
receptors and they are very important
for the understanding of our drug
because they are the ones that in our
opinion and we have evidence for that
will be the first one to respond so that
means that we've already with low doses
of our drug they will it will block
these receptors and and that will lead
to an elevation of dopaminergic function
then what we are looking at here is an
easy the axle of the dopamine ernakulam
but we have of course also similar
receptors in the cell bodies and in the
den was not shown here but so they are
also alter receptors and our function is
to to turn off the dopaminergic activity
if if if there is a tendency for this
activity to get too high in the
extracellular space but the other did
those receptors where you have all these
arrows at the postsynaptic sidehill we
call them hetero receptors so we have
this very important distinction between
autoreceptors and hetero receptors the
first one up front for
the point of view they are operating
antagonistically to each other so you
with het except you refer to any
receptor that is not an author cept
absolute okay because some people use
the word in other meanings but I
understand in fact I think you coined
the term auto sector once didn't you yes
I yes I have to plead guilty and it's
still usable yeah so where does us with
you come in here OSU will OSU 61 62 when
you start with very low doses those
receptors that are on the auto receptors
and also those receptors that are hit or
receptors but are far away from the
synaptic cleft they will be the ones who
will respond first and and so and what
with the outcome of that will be it will
be the effect of the auto receptor on
the auto receptors that will dominate so
therefore the dopaminergic activity will
go up and the animal will move more and
bigger became more wakeful and so forth
but when you increase the dose of of all
our drug it will start more and more to
to stimulate the hetero receptors which
operate in the opposite direction so
therefore you can understand since Tim
let me block the hatred yeah that's the
kind of problem i have sometimes say the
opposite or not like that that's your
very important role here in correcting
me when i say she's always blocking
receptors never acted I can do is it so
you would you explain to our release its
a oh it's osu 61-62 envy though will be
my at blocking agent for the top lock
all the time okay thank you so when you
are when you are blocking the hetero
receptors then the activity of the
animal and the wakefulness and so forth
will come down and what about will it
subsequently affect these receptors in
the indeed in the synaptic region where
the concentrations are high the
postsynaptic receptors normal exposed to
high concentrations we would like to
have the better evidence but what what
we we are I am I am personally convinced
this is the site where these receptors
that are sitting in this thick
postsynaptic membrane for some reason
our molecule cannot bind enough to that
one not enough to cause catalepsy or
extract the w side so that is a lovely
aspect of it yes thank you and I think
we have some data here sire some some
summarizing here synthesis so this is
just to to repeat what the picture to
atone what with what I tell you on the
basis of the picture so first of all if
you if you look at in lethal conditions
our drug will be a blocking agent
altogether nothing else and when you
look at the receptors a different sites
it will be autoreceptors that will will
be hit respond at the lowest level so
that's why you will start out with an
activating effect of the drug but as you
increase those then more and more hetero
receptors will be recruited I will be
bound
we will be blocked and therefore the
increase that you have it low doses in
activity wakefulness and so forth will
will go start to go down again so that's
why you have this biphasic curve if you
if you look at the the entire
extrasynaptic population of hetero
receptors and and compared with the
synaptic hetero receptors you will find
as I said and this is something I would
like to have better evidence for but I
am convinced that the synaptic hetro
receptors they can hardly be hit by by
this by this truck so it's only the
extra synaptic keto receptors that are
involved in the profile of this drug if
you have this preferential you have this
professional blockade of hot receptors
then you should see an increase in
extracellular dopamine levels with for
example in vivo microdialysis do you see
that after with you oh sure absolutely a
very good data in favor of that oh yes
okay so you mentioned the d1 here young
man I think d1 plays a key role for the
profile pharmacologic profile of this
drug and that is because if you if you
have doses of the drug that will block
the auto receptors that will lead to an
activation of the dopaminergic system
the primary neurons and there are some
pathways of dopamine earlier there are
some liberal energy pathways that
targeted where the target new room is
equipped with only d 1 receptors and
therefore since the drug does not bind
or do anything directly to the divine
receptors
what you will have if you when you block
the autoreceptors you will have a
stimulation and indirect stimulation of
the d1 and I think this effect on the D
1 receptors is probably a enormous
importance for the profile of the drug
and that is one that is actually where
the the partial agonist are not doing so
well because with a partial agonist you
will also with those low doses they will
bind through the auto receptors and
thereby reducing the activity of the
dopaminergic neuron and that will lead
to a reduction of d1 so def that's
precisely the reason why the the the
partial agonist they are used they are
useless in our fatigue model and it's
quite a big difference in terms of
synaptic function of course if you have
it it's quite the opposite oh absolutely
Saudi at the balance between d1 and d2 i
think is very important and here we had
one of the keys to the mode of action on
this drug everyone is talking about the
prefrontal cortex when it comes to d1 is
it's a prevent cortex law referring to
it yes certainly it's important but I
think that the the highest density of d1
receptors that you have in the brain are
in the basal ganglia and they are
involved in in a a connection here
between the striatum and the thalamus
and and the deer the d1 is stimulating
on this direct pathway so that the d1
the stimulation of d1 will lead to an
activation or the whole flow of activity
passing through the thalamus so leading
up to the cortex I think even though the
cortex I'm sure it's important but I am
even more impressed by this
I ate them okay direct pathway
interesting so what you want to show
this slide yes i have already referred
to this this is the pit study that has
been done in at university of amsterdam
where healthy volunteers forgiven single
doses or osu 61 62 and and they were
they given a the radioactive rector
pride as it is a indicator here so what
we are seeing what the curve shows here
is the degree the percentage of
displacement of the radioactive fractal
pride by osu 61 62 but and you see it's
a curve that goes up to a it goes
quickly up to about twenty percent and
already at a low class publi level of
osu of point2 just about our point 2
micrograms per liter micro moles per
liter I'm sorry and and this rapid rise
that you have up to from 0 to 0 point to
I think it has a very interesting
mechanism because if you consider the
population of autoreceptors it's a very
small population and also the
extrasynaptic hetero receptors are also
well in the beginning with low doses
they they they cannot they are probably
not enough to explain this degree of
displacement so the the best explanation
that we have today for this rapid
increase up to 20 point to mike moles
per liter is due to an additional effect
and that is that is the effect
blocking autoreceptors lead to if you
block autoreceptors you stimulate the
dopaminergic mm and this leads to an
increased release of dopamine into the
synaptic cleft and and this dopamine
will then this elevated extra cellular
dopamine will then add to the
displacement so this displacement sweet
we see here is due to two different
things direct binding by the drug to the
receptors add to the increase in
dopamine that will add to displacing the
radioactive likened here that's how we
interpret it and obviously you get a
quite a modest blockade here one is
thinking about clozapine which it gets
higher in fact wouldn't this be proof
enough that this will not cause
extrapyramidal side effect you think
could drag dude yes modest yeah that's
that you can look about it this way
absolutely i mean the in order to really
interfere with well I'm my thinking
you'll always some the synaptic cleft
all the time I like even though you can
disregard this idea of the synaptic
cleft as an important aspect to say okay
it's just because it's not it's just
this much already it's not enough all
right another way I have to admit that
this can be interpreted this way also
that bad as i understand you mean that
this very far from completely to detail
is not the same farfel completely to
placate you see by clozapine it's a
different mechanism absolutely so very
different so this is not the clozapine
looking like they're very different than
all i was driving at yeah and by the way
I i we should disregard the fact that
closer peed is not devoid of X
rambutan side effects if you do careful
studies you will you will see them also
that is a controversial statement it
might not agree summer sun so they'll
agree with me yeah so what is this well
what we have seen so far was the
displacement of all the radioactive
writer pride from its binding site in
the straight in the human striatum its
interests and we saw the curve that
turned towards the horizontal leveling
out but if we if we instead we look at
purple acting you will see a curve
that's going straight up all the time so
it is what it shows here is a
confirmation that indeed you have
blockade of dopaminergic receptors
because this is is I think everybody
would agree that this is this please
increasing in prolactin is a sign of a
dopaminergic d2 antagonism and these are
obviously extrasynaptic so they are well
it is well aligned with yes on set
they're not yes they are extra synaptic
and in addition they are located a very
close to the bloodstream they don't have
to have a problem with passing the
blood-brain barrier so and actually
that's are also our experience that with
so far with product in when we are
looking at very low doses in humans that
already very low doses will cause an
increase in productive but there is
another very important thing to add and
that is that within the clinical dose
range you will never get a level of
prolactin that will cause any problems
what your Olympics are so it it was the
only positive things for everything
everything fits amazing obviously
results an argument that this is not a
classic la something because gossiping
would not cause any increase in in
productive in fact it doesn't so so it's
also a difference between this dragon
eternity that's very true you okay I
think we should go forward north to
another transmitter and before we go
into the cell tone the effects of your
drag on serotonin what is your view
everyone else at cell phone is involved
in depression and anxiety you as i said
before develop the first SSRI but what
is your view today about the rellos
atoning for example in psychosis i have
had different views about it over the
years but i have become more and more
convinced that serotonin is also a
player in the mekinese underlying
psychosis and a very interesting aspect
of serotonin in connection with dopamine
is that they seem to be a tandem day
they should be close to each other and
spontaneously if one goes up the other
goes up they follow each other and if
they don't there will be problems
imbalances so therefore it's good to
know that even if we are dealing here in
the case of osu 61 62 only with partial
agonist it's better than nothing so what
what you can see here this is just an
example we have we have evidence in
little as well as you leave evidence for
both an effect of 580 on time 80
receptors on on the inner 582 in the 585
h21 family and the 5-ht to family both
of them but here we what we are looking
at is the only one particular receptor
and that is the five h-2a receptors
and where we have it we have you need to
evidence of the affair and all the
binding there and it is addition the
evidence is that actually invito it more
or less like a full agonist but in vivo
of course not much less I mean as it
usually is but what we see here so this
is a model of 5-ht to activity and the
great column that you have winners three
stars on top is a test drug that is a
classical full agonist and and if you
give this drug to a mouse and and count
the number of head twitches in the
fedora first five minutes you will get
this number that you have here about
five something like so so that is what
the full agonist in der is doing in
terms of head twitches if a rather than
the full agonist you give our drug you
will see that increasing doses will
actually induce head trick because
controls have no hair twitches the word
that you have to the far the far left
you can see that but that that is there
you have zero and but now if you give
increasing doses or of our drug they
will indeed cause he twitches but far
away from the number of hit much less
than the number of it which is that the
DUI drug our full agri-food born artist
is doing so this would be this would be
a nice evidence confirming our in vitro
data that we have indeed a an agonistic
effect but it Leo on on five aces 2a
receptors but not a full agonist it
looks like a person act but in order to
prove partial agonies you
to also be able to demonstrate
antagonise and and here we have the next
slide here again the great first of all
to the far left you have the zero these
are control animals and then the great
big grey column here is our full-blown
DUI agonist which is this madness number
of a very high level of of hit witches
if now on top of T why you give
increasing doses of our drug now they
are inhibitory so that's a classical
example of a partial agonist okay so
when this drug stabilizes dopeman it's
not by partial agonist but when it's
double eyes sir tonin it is classically
partial agonist Asmodeus yeah that is
exactly so and and and as a partial
agonist it's it's not it's not doing the
fabulous things that at least on the
dopamine system is not it's not good but
it's better than nothing okay okay and
these are just two references yeah yeah
because I am I had talked so much now
and you may not believe me but I can
tell you that there is a lot of our data
in the literature and here are two
papers where you have both in vitro and
in vivo data not some them and in
addition to these papers you have
references to other papers so the when I
think I can say that the evidence
underlying my talk here is pretty good
okay I believe you and before now we
shall soon have some questions also but
now we would like to see some clinical
data you have really started clinical
trials with this drug already so please
and tell us about it yes you may wonder
why we have this selected
different disorders dopamine is involved
everywhere so how did we start well in
the beginning with we did the obvious
things get safrina Parkinson's disease
and then we went on from Parkinson's of
course was not a big step to go to
Huntington's disease and then we for
various reasons we went to mems alcohol
dependence and so forth so they'd say it
all together it does in small studies in
the rich are in different stages but if
we go further on and see what we have in
terms of double-blind controlled studies
we have they are in different stages
some are five double-blind controlled
studies have been completed or in
different stages of reporting to have
been published see on the only ready for
reporting to the swedish chef EFTA and
forcibly subsequent publications four of
these studies deal with problems related
to fatigue and one with alcohol
dependence all show improvement compared
to placebo and as then one more control
study that is his law has been completed
but he still and Amy analyses so what I
would like to go from here there would
it would be to look at the the the
defect the studies we with fatigue
because that is the ones mental fatigue
easy these are the ones where we have
the best evidence and what is mental
fatigue it's a common often severely
disabled condition following upon stroke
brain trauma or a connection with
several other brain disorders
the patient can perform intellectual
work for a pretty good but only for a
few hours or so and then and then it
gets very tired I cannot go on anymore
and in addition the patient may find it
difficult to read things such a simple
thing is really a newspaper or take part
in a conversation with several people at
a time so it's a very disabling
condition and that kind of studies we
have done in mental fatigue have been at
or the double-blind crossover design so
as you can see here randomly people the
people the patients get started on
placebo or drug and the dose during four
weeks each there have been increased
starting out a 50 milligrams twice daily
and going in at 230 million goes twice
daily and then that the final two weeks
45 milligrams twice daily and what I
would like to say already here this was
this is what we did in the first study
but in our subsequent studies we cut
down the doses very much because we had
these 45 milligan that twice daily is
for most people an overdose what came
out of this first study worried we had
we ended up with his thoughts with this
overdose nevertheless you read recently
they were they were 12 12 patients and
they were
half of them were following upon stroke
and the other half after by brain trauma
and what you see here is the proportion
of responders in the sense that the
outcome was that it was in favor of drug
compared to placebo so the the blue
columns here show that the majority of
the patients responded in favor of the
drug and if you look at this three with
a star above oldest refer to the far
left you can see that that was only
actually the only one patient who is red
and they responded in the opposite
direction and our there were three wood
who we couldn't decide we couldn't
decide whether I was a difference at all
but the internet it's an interesting
thing with this particular red fellow
who responded in the opposite direction
that what happened with him was that he
got an overdose so at the end of the
four weeks he failed lousy but when he
was switched over to placebo he felt
much better so and we have tried yuni
him in a subsequent open-label study
safety study and we have absolutely
community is an excellent responder when
you say that louse you don't mean next
up for my toe side effects of course not
no but what I feel when they get one
thing but I feel tired it's exactly
according to the textbook yes but of
course I do they have also some
unpleasant feelings in the stomach it
may be a little bit tending to know they
are not for
no nausea but odd in that direction yes
so rather than going through the
different each one of the different
fatigue studies I am what I put together
here is something that I hope will
impress you as a summary what happened
in these double-blind controlled studies
all of them was that it was no question
about the outcome if you compare those
who started with placebo and also
started with active drug those who
started with placebo showed a very clear
response a favorable response whereas
this response was still there it was
also started with active drug but less
much less impressive so what I have done
here I simply to take those patients in
those three now three studies that the
mental fatigue would number one that is
the one I mentioned to you already and
then there is an extended mental fatigue
study with a larger number of patients
and in addition we have Huntington's
patients we're also that the fatigue
aspect is being studied and and the type
of writing had been a little bit
different but not much I mean it's a
matter of fatigue or improving the
fatigue symptoms in all cases and here i
have taken only those patients who
started out with placebo and what you
see here in the different columns you
have the plus and those figures that you
have under plus all those who the
weather response was in favor of
of the drug in comparison to placebo
there is with zero you couldn't decide
the difference and those with minus or
ones who responded in the opposite way
and if we add up all together we have
you can see here all three together you
will see that those who were his who had
a favorable response to the drug 120 I
were to where we couldn't succeed at any
difference and then ever three but was
in the opposite direction and if we do
statistics now and and this now we I am
doing it statistic test that I like very
much the scientist because I consider it
a food proof test so then if you if you
add up the pentalpha tiguan mental
fatigue to and do the scientist on the
basis what what you have here you have a
p-value of 0.00 75 with the mental
fatigue to the extended study you have a
p-value if it that alone when p value of
0.02 25 and if we add up all three we
have P and then you have 0.30 is 49 and
I I would like to to remind you of how
clinical studies usually are you may
need hundreds of patients and you will
end up with a p-value that if you are
happy lucky that I said below p for it
Oh point five so I think maybe yeah I am
at least I am very much impressed by the
outcome okay yeah i'll just mention to
the audience that we have been allowed
by the organizers to go on for a few
minutes after three o'clock so we will
have time for some questions also but we
have a few more slides before that
yeah this slide is also about to tell
you that it is the same studies in fact
yes that is the that is the mental
fatigue the extended mental fatigue too
and what I would like just to bring in
here is that all the evidence that we
could we have so far and that I have
told you about was without any it
without bringing the plasma levels of
the drug and but if we do that we will
see that you will get additional
information that will also very strongly
support the efficacy of these drugs so
if you have all right here we are yes if
we have now you must look at the the
field in circles and the top the number
da figure here the top one and you look
at the filled circles they are the ones
the patients who started with placebo
and you can see there that there is only
one filled circle that is below zero in
other words who got wells where is all
the rest of the field circus when there
were two of them who were on zero but
all the rest were a bomb so I mean again
if you use the scientists here there is
no doubt that you have will will this
the particular score which is it's an
interesting score by the way if a fi I
score because what it tells you is
actually it answer the questions what
did i do more or less during a period of
exposure to the drug
and compared to placebo and in the
outcome is that it looks as our data we
have other data in favor of that that
the what really happens first when the
patients respond is that I start without
even thinking about it they start to do
more it's not just the everyday
household work and thats offer is doing
something beyond that I mean something
that have been you have been waiting for
you to do all of a sudden you get
started over the toe you you get out you
baby would do some work in the garden or
you take you go out for two to visit
somebody to which you couldn't didn't
have the energy to do before so it's
very very clear effect and more and more
so than the MF s scale which is the ball
is the fatigue scale it's not so
striking but even that one even that one
if you look at the filled circles again
but now if you only look at those who
are or with plasma levels beyond Oh
point eight then you will find 66 points
here and six and six points or if six if
six patients improve and there is nobody
doing the opposite that's artistically
significant so I think that but at the
same time if you look at the trend for
therefore if you take now all all those
though both those who started with
placebo and I was those who started with
with active drug that is you can see
that as clear tendency especially in the
in the lower the graph and EMFs graph
that if you go beyond if you go beyond
open
date it looks not impressive at all that
you actually you have a it you have less
of an out card you have a poor outcome
actually so again if we look at the
whole thing again we are seeing this
curve starting out from in far left from
zero then going up and then going beyond
a point eight it's going down again so
we we have this by face occur that we're
so already in in the rodents yes
fascinating yes this is a what next
slide yeah please take that faster than
I have one more question yes what we now
want to do of course is to do an
extended safety study because all the
olders studies we have done so far have
been not beyond four weeks exposure to
drug now we go we are extending this and
now we have one I'm sorry there is a
sprint it all this should be a 180-day
safety test duration to those titration
study in mental fatigue failure patients
of different diagnosis so that is what
we are what's going on now it is very it
shows very new interesting information
for especially that if you go on week
after week and the patient has improved
perhaps already at the during the first
few weeks but then if you go up they get
better and better week after week month
after month so is so we are what we have
been seeing in the four weeks has just
been in the beginning I mean it's even
in a better so and and we want to tend
to increase increase the scope to
include patients with F different
disorders you know such as ADHD in turn
is inclined to volatile
that / if we have any time would be nice
if we could talk because this that is
well where you have done such
interesting work yeah we have found us a
clear-cut entire aggression effect of
this drug is student it extended that
were also again you have a situation
where you probably have more dopeman
usual in the rodents and where you see
very clear-cut and ty aggressive effect
with the new effect of locomotion so
also that's obviously nine o'clock you
have been claiming here but let ya yes I
say it has been followed up by soda an
application has now been submitted to
our little Swedish FDA or min term is a
kind of violence so this will be being
clinical study will hopefully get
started within the couple of months
exciting finally before we have one or
two questions from the audience before
we finish this and I think this focus of
fatigue is in fact very interesting it's
always nice when commendable and found
one and new diagnosis is in focus that
has been objected before that back then
there are as you mentioned here many
other possible conditions and one could
of course mentioned the obvious ones
schizophrenia bipolar disorder etc if
you should guess what would be the most
important indication for this compound
of all possibility cases well today I
what I am thinking perhaps most is the
is the aging problem and the dementia I
feel proper yeah but I feel convinced
that with this drug we shall be able I
practically almost convinced with this
drug we shall be able to postpone the
period of we will all get demented if we
get old enough but the day when this
becomes troublesome will be postponed by
several years by this drug
I wouldn't have guessed that that
interesting fascinating and we have gone
over time here but I think we should
have a few questions from the audience
we are allowed that by the organizers
and then and I shall see if I have
received any questions here just a
second here we first have a question
what is the effect of this drug on
memory that is close to what you Justin
yes the d there is definitely a in
effect on called cognitive functions but
it it thats in the sense perhaps mostly
of of the fatigue i mean ii if the
patient is well rested in those those
studies we are done the cognitive
functions seem to be rather good but
they don't they get tired and I stopped
thinking after they intellectual work
for any period of time more than an hour
or so can be quite a problem but in the
case of dementia alzheimer my prediction
would be that the cognitive aspects are
not the ones that will be well you have
the big base effect it will be rather on
other aspects or emotional aspects and
so forth or the dementia of Alzheimer
here's one question I don't know if you
can answer to that for various reasons
but someone here is asking what data of
the US who was you drag for alcohol or
drug abuse did the speaker have so far
clinical a shower or there are all right
oh yes oh yes that is the data that the
study that has been done at the college
the institute has been completed and is
ready almost ready for for reporting and
publications and it's very clear-cut
effect there is a statistically
significant effect this is a two-armed
study
30 plus 30 patients I think it was 30 on
on drugs 30 or placebo and as there was
a statistically significant favorable
outcome and incidentally it was found
that those patients who had a high
tendency to impulsive behavior they were
the ones who responded they will see
with little Ian festivities the Darius
didn't respond this was what what did
the study actually dealt with was the
the seeking the drug-seeking behavior
that's nothing unfortunately we have got
a lot of questions and I think we only
have time for one more and that would be
a good osu 61 62 reverse the effect of
long-term antipsychotic medications yes
I think so because yes because and of
course there are some some effect that
maybe I mean if you have severe tardive
dyskinesia for example it I am not sure
if that might in fact yeah yes yes it's
quite fit it's not yeah I mean I love
and hyperactive oh sure and are you sure
yes yes I mean we have we have this
aspect of plasticity plasticity has come
down very strongly due to the present
drugs so and if you allow for plasticity
to come back I think you can do a lot I
would like to thank the audience for
being with us and for posting these
questions and as I said we have had many
more before we say goodbye for today I
would just like to ask you what you
think you have been at numerous
Congress's of course in your life what
do you think about this format for
scientific exchange do you like it it's
quite new for both of us especially if I
speak for myself this is my only
opportunity I have to take party
scientific meetings unless
or in gothenburg because i don't travel
anymore so this is there it is what is
left for me and I am so pleased about
this but this is freaky for my selfie
thinking in general terms I think this
it has this way or communication has a
tremendous future suckling absolutely
okay then I guess would like to thank
again I recall some for sharing his
ideas about this amazing drag and the
concept of dopamine stabilization and to
the organizers of this event and to the
audience and thank you very much for
having been with us bye bye